parce que nos vies se transforme
perpétuellement nous avons le devoir de
recycler tous ces maillots yprema votre
partenaire pour un développement durable
bonjour et bienvenue dans équilibre
votre magazine dédié à l'environnement
pour ce premier numéro de la saison nous
allons découvrir comment la nature gagne
du terrain en ville les entreprises par
exemple sont de plus en plus nombreuses
à favoriser la biodiversité le verrou
dans un instant mais avant cela
rencontre avec l'association le vivant
et la ville elle développe des projets
agricoles en milieu urbain
friches industrielles décharges terrain
vague
comment revaloriser les espaces urbains
délaissés l'association le vivant et la
ville a trouvé une solution plutôt
originale et écologique créer des fermes
en ville économiquement autonome et pour
reconquérir des terrains parfois pollue
et on mise sur la culture hors sol la
première initiative vient de voir le
jour à saint cyr l'école il y a encore
deux ans ce terrain de 3,5 hectares
était une décharge laissée à l'abandon
la caf entreprises qui sont associés qui
sont les jardins gamme hydra sol seul
paysage et veolia pour développer les
ferland ville donc c'est un projet
collectif c'est l'ingénierie collectif
qui a été développé en 22 mois
on est parti d'une friche donc terrain
abandonné qu'il y avait des carcasses de
voitures ou il ya des pneus où il y
avait des blocs de béton et on l'a
réhabilité pour donner aujourd'hui ce
projet ce projet repose sur trois
activités la première d'entre elles la
production bienvenue dans la zone de
production de la ferme
donc on a ici un hectare de culture sous
filet on a utilisé un filet parce que ça
protège de la grêle ça protège du vent
donc mine de rien on augmente la
température donc un effet de serre qui
est intéressant et pour l'agriculteur
c'est beaucoup moins cher qu'une serre
cette année près de 20 tonnes de tomates
cerises fraises et framboises seront
récoltés la production fonctionnent en
économie circulaire pour l'irrigation de
l'eau de pluie récupérée dans ce bassin
de rétention
la récolte sera vendu dans un rayon de
20km à la ferme de gally dans des
supermarchés ou encore dans ce tout
nouveau distributeur automatique
je vous présente kane qui est donc le
maraîcher en charge de la partie
production
ken est permanent sur le site de quatre
à six saisonniers l'épaule selon les
besoins l'intérêt du huard sol c'est
qu'on peut en fait importer sur
n'importe quel endroit donc à ce qu'on
fait ici peut être refait ailleurs sur
un toit dans l'année
vraiment n'importe où donc on
s'affranchit complètement du sol en plus
là on les a mis à hauteur d'homme donc
au niveau de la récolte on est beaucoup
plus efficace on n'a pas de problèmes
musculo squelettiques
il ya la posture du travail donc le
travail se fait plus vite les fraises
sont pas en contact direct du sol donc
elles vont pas pourrir pour en fait ça
présente que des avantages
autre atout ce type d'exploitation est
amovible une fois démonté il ne laissera
aucune trace
le but du démonstrateur est aussi
d'expliquer ce qu'est la culture hors
sol et d'initier les particuliers pour
cela une zone pédagogique a été créé le
but étant de montrer au public
il ya plein de techniques hors sol qui
existe et on veut vraiment dé diaboliser
ces techniques montrer qu'il ya des
choses très rustique et on peut faire un
potager en fait suspendu en étant
quasiment bio mais en effet on est hors
sol donc on commence là si vous voulez
par le plus simple dans le monde du hors
sol sait on prend un ballot de paille on
le fait composter donc pendant quinze
jours il va chauffer en fête et au sein
du balo va se développer un seul et en
suisse et dans ce seul qu'on va planter
et ça donne alors j'en avais cours l'un
des salades dans ces bacs en bois on
teste différents substrats pour comparer
leur efficacité et savoir si un déchets
urbains peut devenir une ressource
concassé de briques pour les faits
drainant mélange de marc de café et de
champignons et bien sûr déchets verts
déjà versé une taille de hesse et de la
tonte c'est plein de choses comme ça
qu'on passe à déchets verts et en fait
ça devient un super bon support de
culture donc sur le test en comparaison
avec un apéro classique achetés dans le
commerce
un peu plus loin c'est tour agricole
récupère l'eau de pluie une pompe à
énergie solaire permet l'irrigation peut
tout à fait imaginer ça en milieu urbain
donc c'est un ensemble commercial à des
endroits parce que comme on voit c'est
en étage donc on augmente la surface au
sol
dans un registre plus moderne qui se
veut aussi une source d'inspiration
architectural ses installations
hydroponique
on a un bac avec de l'eau dedans avec
une pompe qui pousse l'eau tout en haut
et ensuite un système de douche qui
vient irriguer l'ensemble des cultures
donc on a juste juste c'est pas un sol
c'est juste un support qui permet de
tenir les racines et ensuite au sein de
la colonne les racines viennent
directement au contact de l'eau pour
prendre les minéraux et poussé
simplement ici les minéraux ne viennent
plus de la terre en 2015 ce
démonstrateur d'agriculture urbaine
lancera sa troisième activités la
location de jardin hors sol pour le
grand public à l'instar des jardins
familiaux
de quoi donner des idées pour le toit de
son immeuble et puis évidemment il n'y a
pas que des friches en ville en compte
aussi beaucoup d'entreprises des
paysages et leur propose d'utiliser leur
site pour créer des jardins vivant
rencontre avec l'un d'entre eux
olivier baduel bonjour je vous êtes le
fondateur de vrd qu une entreprise de
paysages vous proposez vos services aux
entreprises alors comment les aider à se
mettre au vert voilà donc vers des
causses est une entreprise qui fait du
paysage d'intérieur et du paysage
extérieur donc pour les entreprises on
propose un service de mise en place de
plantes d'intérieur avec un contrat
d'entretien pour pour ses plantes et
pour les extérieurs
on propose l'aménagement de terrasses
avec notre bureau d'études est en étude
et en réalisations les jardins
entreprises ce n'est pas quand même
quelque chose de nouveau
avant c'était un peu plus de la
décoration qu'est ce que c'est devenu
aujourd'hui
alors c'est devenu un lieu utilitaires
les jardins en entreprise et de son plus
en plus utilisé par les collaborateurs
et donc on va chercher à avoir plutôt
une terrasse plutôt un lieu de détente
pour le midi pour les fumeurs aussi et
donc ce lieu maintenant et très vivant
et contribuer au bien-être des
collaborateurs en entreprise vous
proposait d'ailleurs desjardins vivant
alors là on va travailler avec l'animal
on va travailler avec les oiseaux avec
le mouton la poule
on va essayer de proposer une autre
façon de désherber les massifs
on met plus dans donc de pesticides ou
de choses qui peuvent polluer la nappe
phréatique voilà on essaie de travailler
dans dans ce secteur là est-ce que vous
avez aujourd'hui plus de demandes
qu'auparavant est ce que les entreprises
ont plus demandeuses
ce qui est sûr c'est que les entreprises
elles elles recherchent encore elles
recherchent beaucoup le bien-être de
leurs collaborateurs et le jardin aussi
bien en intérieur qu'en extérieur
contribue à ce bien-être au fait que les
collaborateurs ont envie de venir
travailler à l'entreprise et de sortir
bien et donc effectivement il ya une
demande de plus en plus forte pour
travailler dans ce sens là on va le voir
dans un instant c'est finalement une
solution économique on peut aller voir
du coup les l'écopâturage mais on peut
les voir les copains tu vois je vais
vous montrer
patrick le bélier allons-y donc voici
patrick kane alors que vient faire un
mouton dans une entreprise
alors donc déjà ça c'est une race tonnes
et marteau et le mouton dans
l'entreprise va apporter du lien social
entre les collaborateurs
il va bien sûr entretenir aussi les
jardins et pour les
les entreprises qui ont de grandes
surfaces de de terrain est bien le
mouton va remplacer quelque part
l'intervention humaine dans l'entretien
du jardin
ce qui finalement baisse les cours par
ça pour des grandes surfaces
effectivement ça baisse les coûts et on
arrive à être très compétitifs et avoir
un
on apporte du vivant dans le jardin et
donc on contribue aussi au développement
de la biodiversité dans le jardin on
propose également des cool alors on
propose aussi des poules
alors ça c'est par exemple on en propose
à neuilly dans des petits patios on met
des poules on passe régulièrement pour
entretenir bien sûr et le bruit de la
poule
contribuer à donner une image de
l'entreprise un peu cool on va dire et
puis aussi les collaborateurs il
apprécie énormément quand les poussant à
ils peuvent récupérer les voilà une
petite histoire qui se fait tout au long
de la journée
merci beaucoup favoriser la biodiversité
un geste citoyen que les entreprises
commencent donc à intégrer
nous avons rencontré deux sociétés assez
exemplaire dans ce domaine
reportage ces moutons ne broute pas dans
un champ en pleine campagne mais sur le
site d'une entreprise pour les 3000
mètres carrés qui entoure son dépôt de
trappes nature et découvertes a opté
pour deux l'écopâturage ses moutons
remplace la tondeuse
on va les mettre devant l'entrepôt je
vais lui l'armée à ses hôtes aussi pour
le maître bien le plus propre possible
et ensuite dix 1 1 à 2 mois on va les
mettre sur l'arrière de l'autre ces huit
moutons d'ouessant sont loués à une
société qui passent tous les quinze
jours pour les soins vétérinaires
l'eau reste du temps ce sont les
salariés de l'entrepôt qui s'en occupe
ils sont très dociles on a envie de les
caresser même s'ils sont très peureux
voilà donc ça fait les gens ont envie de
s'y intéresser et de venir les voir
donc voilà ça aussi un rôle social car
l'entreprise souhaite impliquer son
personnel sur chaque site une dizaine de
salariés volontaires constituent un
réseau vert ils sont chargés de
favoriser la biodiversité ici
l'écopâturage mais aussi des ruches ou
encore des arbres fruitiers
quand vous êtes dans votre métier ce qui
vous parle c'est donner un peu de sens à
ce que vous faites donc bas de façon
intrinsèque votre métier peut vous
donner du sens mais tout ce que vous
pouvez mettre tour pour compléter lui
donner un peu de richesse
ben c'est toujours très bienvenu
vis-à-vis des salariés
autre solution pour les entreprises
transformer ces espaces verts en prairie
à orgeval la société chinatsu voulait
faire de son siège social
la vitrine de ses valeurs
environnementales il y a trois ans une
belle pelouse verdoyante occuper
l'espace il y avait à peu près de tonte
par mois ça faisait 26 à 24 tonnes à
l'année
donc c'était très polluants puisque
c'était effectivement fait
de façon traditionnelle et puis on avait
vraiment un gazon vert sans vie qui
étaient traités avec des pesticides et
du coup on voulait donner vie à cette
pré rien l'entreprise a signé un écho
contrat avec un autre prestataire
aujourd'hui le terrain est fauché que
deux fois dans l'année
la dernière date du début du mois on
retrouve une vingtaine de variétés de
plantes indigènes alors des plantes
indigènes c'est des plantes qu'on n'a
pas été cherché partout en france c'est
vraiment des plantes qu'on retrouve
localement dans tous nos jardins dans
tous les espaces verts qu'on peut
retrouver en région parisienne du
géranium sauvage oblige
pour les autres espaces verts aussi les
produits phytosanitaires sont bannis on
utilise des copeaux de bois issus des
coupes d'arbres
ça a un double effet d'une part sur les
mauvaises herbes et aussi sur l'aspect
d'irrigation étant donné qu'on n'y
arrive plus du tout on arrose plus du
tout non
nos espaces verts pour aller plus loin
des ruches ont été installées les
abeilles ne sont pas les seuls à être
protégé cet hôtel à insectes est un abri
pour de multiples espèces en cas
d'intempéries la société ne compte pas
s'arrêter là en potager est à l'étude
on finit avec l'agenda rendez vous le 27
septembre au scarabée à la verrière pour
le festival des alternatives écologiques
économiques et sociales l'association
alternatiba sky vous a concocté tout un
programme rencontres conférences mais
aussi concerts et puis les 11 et 12
octobre pour ceux qui voudraient rendre
leur habitat plus écologique le forum
eco habitat se tiendra à la fondation
coubertin à saint rémy les chevreuse
c'est la fin de ce magazine à merci de
nous avoir suivis je vous donne rendez
vous le mois prochain et d'ici là prenez
soin de la planète